what we're gonna do is we'll tidy up
this is the last question here 5d I
guess I know a few of you were kind of
looking at the sideways you like art but
it's not obvious what do I do
well tidy this up we'll tie in a nice
bow and then we'll move on to the second
half of this will be quick up there
heading that we did write this out of it
oh okay so this is the circle that they
give you some of it is easy to see and
some of that's not so easy so we're
being asked to find the center and the
radius of this circle which of those two
piece information is easier to see the
center right it's like smack bang there
so you can all tell me that the center
has coordinates 1 comma 1 so happy times
with that but then you look and there's
not any nice neat point they like they
don't tell you how far away this is like
what that x-coordinate is so you can't
easily calculate it but I want you to
remember like the radius what is the
radius is the distance from the center
the center which is often at the at the
origin but not always from the center -
where - anywhere on the circumference
right the radius goes from the center to
anywhere so for example whatever the
radius is that's how long it is right
just so happens that that's not a very
useful place to go because I don't know
anything about this point right where
might be a more useful point on the
circumference I could use like a soccer
got to here right from the center so
this spot on the circumference that will
be the radius I'm going to go ahead and
say there's an even easier place you
could go the origin is also right on the
circumference right and because that's
there I can draw myself a nice neat
right-angled triangle and you already
know how tall the right angle triangle
is it's one you know how wide the right
angle triangles it's also one so you can
use what we started off today with
Pythagoras and you record oh this is one
one and root - okay so if that's the
radius if the radius equals root two
what will the equation be
let's start with some brackets rather
than throwing out random numbers okay I
shall enjoy to start us off don't do the
whole thing just start us off okay so
I'm gonna have something squared it's
gonna be X minus 1 or square can someone
else take a I've done the X so I'm going
to Y minus 1 well squared and then that
equals to just 2 because the square root
of the right-hand side
am i nicely formed that's it that's the
radius to understand semicircles before
we get to all these weird wacky crazy
ones with weird centers and weird radii
it's often helpful in maths to when
you're going into a new area start with
the simplest version of what you can now
what was the simple object that we
started today with we didn't just look
at any circle we look at a specific one
the unit circle right so we're gonna
start with the unit circle again right
this guy here x squared plus y squared
equals 1 it's a nice simple object and
we can use it bless you to work out what
semi circles are like okay now XY plus y
squared centers at the origin radius is
equal to 1 what I'm gonna do here with
you is if we make if we rearrange this
equation such that we have X or Y as the
subject it will make it really easy to
see what the semicircle is let me show
you okay for instance all of the
parabolas and hyperbolas and straight
lines we're used to seeing them in this
form right y equals whatever y equals MX
plus C or y equals ax squared plus BX
plus C or 1 on X or whatever right we
usually make Y the subject so here what
would happen what do I need to do first
to make Y the subject can anyone tell me
the first step that might be helpful
okay I'm going to subtract C this x
squared here as Reston's identified that
doesn't belong I want it to be on the
other side so I'm going to subtract from
both sides so you can follow along with
me I get this so far so good now I
wanted a y equals some stuff right not a
y squared equals some stuff so if I've
got something squared what should i do
both sides take the square root right
now just be cautious with this next bit
because if for example you had a
question you don't need to write this
down
if I had a question like this x squared
equals 25 right you can take the square
root on the left hand side but you know
you don't just write a single number on
the right hand side right it's not just
5 it's plus or minus because both of
those can get squared to be give you 25
same thing applies here so I'm going to
write plus or minus and then what do I
write square root of all of the stuff
that's here 1 minus X square okay now
what this is remember plus or minus is
just a lazy mathematicians way of saying
two separate things and I'd love us to
write what those two separate things are
so this is shorthand for just like in
the quadratic equation quadratic formula
sorry to completely separate things
there's the negative one like this and
then there's also the positive one when
there's a plus one minus x squared okay
now what you're staring at right now two
semicircles
right and you can tell me which ones
they are cuz the square root this guy
over here when it's positive this thing
is only can only be positive values
right like I know that this is plus or
minus five but what's the square root of
16 it's just four it's not negative four
right it's just four so see this guy
here this is only positive so the range
of this is going to be a bar zero so
we're on my unit circle
will this be it's going to be the the
top part right so this guy up here in
fact I'm leaving a drawer as search this
guy up here is the positive square root
of one minus x squared that makes sense
this is y equals the square root of one
minus x squared right and you know you
might have des most nearby you might be
able to chuck in y equals the square
root of 1 minus x squared there is right
so there's our semicircle just like we
expected okay
what's the other part can tell you
because this is like both of them this
one says both of them
if this is sorry said again what's
x-squared
yes so it kind of looks like a parabola
right you're on X we're but that's
square root kind of turns into the
circle so see how this is the top half
right this is the top half what happens
when you slap a minus sign on the front
it gets to gives you the bottom half
right so this is underneath so if you go
to DES well so you just chucking it and
minus sign at the front
BAM they go there's the underneath
there's the other semicircle okay so
you've got top half it's the plus you
have the bottom half
look at that minus sign it's there okay
so this is top and bottom how would we
do left and right what you thinking um
okay so you see how when we went through
right we started with this guy and we
made Y the subject okay if we went
through and made X the subject instead
yeah you're just like you're literally
swapping all the X's and Y's around do
you see that right so underneath here I
don't even think you need to do the
working right you're going to get x
equals if I'm a Texas subject set a
wider subject you're still gonna have a
plus or minus right you're still going
to have this square root and then you
get 1 minus y squared now just like
before
this is shorthand for two separate
things there's going to be the negative
one and the positive one which one do
you think is the left and which one is
the right conveniently the negative one
is to the left because look at the our
axes right to the left over here is
negative values of X so this guy here is
the left
and that leaves this guy as the right
Hoff and just like before if you'll bear
with me while I fiddle with my equation
I'm glad you like that there you go
there's the right hands semicircle just
like we saw the fall okay I made X the
subject and because X is about left and
right and if you're restricted to
positive values you go to the right okay
it's pretty neat right now the tricky
thing is that the water gets deep pretty
fast after this and I'm gonna let you
guys explore something on your own what
circle we'll be playing with to make the
bottom on the top the left and the right
we've been playing with the unit circle
the whole time right so if I wanted a
semicircle that was not centered on the
origin that perhaps didn't have a radius
of exactly one these numbers are going
to become a little more complicated let
me give you an example you don't have to
write this down just to think throw with
me right what if you saw something like
this okay this is relatively if I've
only change one thing okay so think
about this right you could check this
you know how we started with this and
then we made Y the subject right you can
do this in Reverse country I will first
note that Y has a range restriction on
it it's greater than or equal to zero
because if this is square root I can
never get a negative out of that okay
and then I'm gonna start doing stuff to
this square both sides you okay with
that and then I'm going to add x squared
to both sides you know what this is
center is at the origin radius is radius
is three this is um this is three square
right how about something like this
I'm not even gonna rearrange it this
time have a look at it what do you think
at 25 tell you why the radius is this
thing under here right it's going to be
the square root of 25 the radius is 5
what do you think this tells you this
tells you about the shift right yeah
it's a Y so it's up down is it up where
is it down put into desmos have a look
it's up by the way it's up okay so you
can see they're gonna start to get it a
little more complicated as you move them
around as you make them smaller or
bigger but it's the same deal okay